it's time for pop quiz
and guess who's been selected zulaira
are you there yes i'm here
there you are hi yeah
oh my gosh this is like a dream come
true for me oh for us
too zuleira okay now guess what if you
correctly answer all three questions
about today's show
then you will win one thousand dollars
or a hundred dollars for each
question answered right zulera are you
ready
i'm ready all right let's do this okay
first question
what international holiday are we
celebrating today
do women who do yeah international
women's day yes
yes okay
second question thank you i'm so nervous
how many greens does dawn russell's
chewable tablets contain
like like i don't know 50 or something
no okay eight greens but another chance
to win a hundred bucks oh wow
final question all right for another
hundred dollars
what is the in style color of the moment
the color potato
potato brown thank you zulaira that is
200
for getting two answers right yes
thank you and guess what everybody next
time our pop quiz piggy bank
rolls over to the next show so it will
be worth
2 000 so pay attention oh my gosh
thank you so much and before we go in
honor of international women's day
i wanted to um mention a really special
initiative that i'm proud to say
flower beauty the makeup company that we
started 10 years ago is a part of cvs's
beauty unaltered campaign
and its goal is to honor everyone's
authenticity and diversity
so to celebrate being our most authentic
selves
cvs is giving everyone in the audience a
50 gift card
yes and we're also giving away
this exclusive product to cvs is called
color shift
it's a lip smoothie that's my personal
recommendation so you'll each be getting
one of these and what i love about it is
when you put it on your lips it's like a
mood lip gloss
it really enhances your own natural lip
color so it's individual just like every
woman herself
so thank you very much for watching
everyone at home
and our vfs thank you rossie
thank you we hope you have a great day
thank you so much
[Music]
you